Pixar is famous for dropping Easter eggs throughout
their films, and the Toy Story franchise's
fourth installment is full of tiny details
only the most eagle-eyed viewers will catch.
Here's a list of things you probably missed
in Toy Story 4.
Toy Story 4 starts with a flashback to nine
years earlier, where Woody and Bo Peep are
conducting a rescue mission to save Andy's
remote control toy car, RC, from being swept
away in a rainstorm.
Luckily, the team is able to save RC just
as a real car pulls into the Davis' driveway.
This crucial scene reveals where in the world
Bo Peep was in Toy Story 3, because the person
driving the car is there to take her away.
If tears aren't clouding your eyes, you may
be able to make out the letters and numbers
on the car's license plate: RMR F97.
In a 2019 press conference, producer Mark
Nielsen revealed that those letters and digits
were fully intentional, saying:
"On Toy Story 2, there was someone who worked
on the show that accidentally deleted the
movie from the render farm.
[That] was the command on the computer that
deleted the film."
Producer Jonas Rivera added:
"It felt appropriate that the license plate
on the car that takes Bo away would be the
same that killed Toy Story 2."
Randy Newman's cheery song, "You've Got a
Friend In Me," was the theme song for the
very first Toy Story movie, and has since
been used in each of its sequels.
The famous song made a welcome comeback with
Toy Story 4, but the film also graced fans
with two brand spankin' new Randy Newman tunes.
The first of said tunes, "I Can't Let You
Throw Yourself Away," can be heard during
the montage of Woody quite literally not letting
Forky throw himself away.
"You're Bonnie's toy.
You are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life."
"Huh, what?"
"Oh, ah, ugh!"
A more appropriate song title has never existed.
As Newman explained:
"[Forky] gets it in his head that he's disposable,
so he keeps trying to throw himself in the
trash can … and Woody has put himself in
charge of keeping him from doing so."
The second of the singer-songwriter's new
original songs is the backing track for the
film's end credits — though Newman gave
his voice a break for this one.
Instead, country crooner Chris Stapleton lent
his vocal talent to the Western-inspired tune,
titled, "The Ballad of the Lonesome Cowboy."
Though fans had long speculated that Pixar
films were all connected in some way, writer
Jon Negroni popularized the idea with a viral
2013 blog post titled "The Pixar Theory."
In his post, Negroni put forth the idea that
Boo — the adorable little girl from Monsters,
Inc. — is actually the witch from Brave.
You know, the witch who transformed Brave's
villain Mor'du from a prince to a bear.
As Negroni explained:
"She probably wanted to turn him into a bear
because [Sulley] resembles a bear, and she
is still trying to figure out where [Sulley]
comes from."
As outlandish as it may sound, there seem
to be a couple of Easter eggs hidden throughout
Toy Story 4 that will make the hearts of Pixar
Theory believers soar.
During Bonnie's first day of Kindergarten,
an out-of-focus Boo seemingly sits just a
few tables away — but the more obvious egg
comes in the form of Bunny, one of the stuffed
prizes Buzz meets at the carnival.
As Entertainment Weekly notes, the fuzzy,
floppy-eared, blue-and-green Bunny bears a
striking resemblance to Sulley the monster.
Here's hoping Boo's family makes a trip to
the carnival!
When Toy Story 3 was released in June 2010,
fans were appalled to see Bo Peep, as well
as her beloved sheep, Billy, Goat, and Gruff,
had seemingly been erased.
Fortunately, the fourth installment of the
franchise made it up to fans in a major way
by putting Bo and her journey to be more than
just a toy collecting dust on a shelf front-and-center.
"Woody, who needs a kid's room when you can
have all of this?"
In a press conference, director Josh Cooley
revealed:
"Having Bo come back was the genesis of this
film.
We even called the movie 'Peep," which was
our code name."
The fan favorite's return was announced in
January 2019 with a short video of Bo startling
Buzz and Woody by bursting through a wall
behind them, wielding her trademark crook.
However, much to the surprise of fans, her
signature pink dress and bonnet were nowhere
to be found.
Instead, the new-and-improved Bo sports a
baby-blue jumpsuit with ruffled accents and
cap sleeves, along with a pink sash tied around
her waist.
If you found yourself wishing you, too, could
sport Bo's new look — we have good news.
ShopDisney.com has the entire look available
for just $168.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.